hey welcome back to new rock stars this
is a big question the show that gives
you too much information about the
things that are out there that are
implied by past things and may be coming
to kill you but hey this is your daily
dose of distraction here and new rock
stars we're still hanging out we're
still doing our thing Cheers I think
biologically sutures clink prophylactic
Cheers
wrap it up kids yeah as you can see
Phillip and I are practicing safe social
distancing during this time but we're
scrappy enough operation here in new
rock stars it's very few people we have
a skeleton crew skeleton crew in that
and that they're all skeletons now
because we made them work during the
growth six feet apart we got a barrier
here we have not touched in days anyone
anyone has touched anyone in days but
really what we're talking about today is
like how things have like reshaped our
lives and yeah we were having this
conversation about how everything's
going to change now and how you know
some people are gonna want to work from
home forever or kids are like not gonna
go back to school or something or
apparently the government wants me to
send them money right now which is also
like that is not happening bill hexes
money isn't real anymore we're American
revolutionaries right so we don't have
to pay taxes yeah so what that was about
well and then we started to apply this
to the MCU because that's the universe
we prefer to live in right now and they
actually have these kind of like scary
threats that are basic implications and
things that have happened that if you
think about this too hard all kinds of
horrible truths exist in the MCU that we
got to talk about Eric you asked me this
week what are the things that keep me up
at night basically about the MCU and I
got to thinking and I I've had a lot of
time that I should have put toward
anything else but instead I started
thinking like okay technically if this
happened in this movie then doesn't that
mean this and then I got scared and then
I had an answer to your question so
let's do it the things that the MCU has
not addressed that are terrifying
of course of course
first up dr. strange Dormammu yes okay
Dormammu is not gone think about this
okay yes not only see like oh he got
beat by the time loop or whatever and
then he was just like fine I won't
destroy everything right now but two
things
he's like eternal so he's just still
there if he once again is like you know
what I'm gonna destroy everything and
then dr. strange is like ah I'll use my
time loop jzuk he just pops dr. strange
he's like I already know the time loop
trick now the one thing that was ever
able to stop Dormammu has been used up
and he's it's not like he also erased
his memory right so we can never undo
that and their mommas again eternal
Doctor Strange is like what he's got 30
years left and then was that the time
stone is obliterated it is yet on we
used to do this
so if Dormammu knows that like that's
all he knew would he know that
it was you know it was the one nuclear
deterrent that kept her mommy from
attacking this dimension from the Dark
Dimension was the fact that Doctor
Strange might have already set a time
loop just like a time loop home defense
security system and that's gone yeah
that's why people kill mongers should
come back I mean I love kill monger but
like Dormammu the the freaking like
thing where he looks like one of those
puzzles that splits apart the different
layers he's just like floating head out
there right now floating head but I but
at any moment he could be again now I
feel like destroy everything and we have
no defense against that pretty much no
defense if the time stone was the one
defense it's gone and we're screwed by
this demon this Lovecraftian demon that
is standing behind me right now that was
number one Dormammu keeps me up at night
I'm terrified of them up next speaking
of these weird floating heads in space
so I'm watching
guardians trying to look for that
elusive Easter egg and we meet the
collector do you remember where the
collector lives yeah he lives in nowhere
do you remember where nowhere is it's
the the severed head of a celestial it's
the beam severed head of a celestial
last episode we talked about how big a
deal the Celestials are right can they
be killed by just old age stray viruses
no you can't even conceive killing a
celestial and yet there is a severed
head of one floating in space just
rotting and they built a little city in
it and people who live in it what did
that Oh what did they killed uh Celeste
you don't like ripped its head off a
giant safe that's even more by hand I'm
imagining like just like like if you
look at nowhere it's like a floating
head a little bit of spinal cord nah
just a little bit of a cute little bit
did your spinal cord
I mean Marvel has gods they're called as
Guardians they're called the Eternals
and above those gods are the Celestials
those socials are just gods they're like
the gods of the gods yeah so and we've
seen one and all we saw was it's ripped
off corpse like imagine like you're
walking to school or whatever and you
just see like a decapitated head of like
a real big strong guy okay which is
important if it's just a normal
decapitated head you're like no big but
how can you tell from the head alone
that it was a big strong thick neck neck
that's the cast neck if I saw that I'm
like who did that who did that just a
little bit of piss goes down your leg
yeah sprinklers yeah there are things
that are more powerful than Celestials
but like it's terrifying to know that
they're around and they can do that I
mean I think the question there and
people can let me know is it Galactus
was just like yeah yeah that's the only
man I collect this is mo he feeds off
the energy of dying planets he doesn't
like getting fistfights with Celestials
where he turns into the mountain on Game
of Thrones so just saying something
insanely huge and terrifying is out
there just like or eating the body maybe
it's a bunch of piranhas like yeah
little piranhas and just eat the body
away or just like billions of
normal-sized piranhas and then that
social just won't even be another how
many would be enough let's do the math
[Music]
up next this is more one of these like
you know I don't smoke lift a lot of
people are not gonna believe but it's
the kind of like thought you have when
you've been smoking and and you're tired
and you're trying to get scared for some
reason I cuz like Friday the 13th
think about Ultron for a second does do
you well know okay great thank you
number three do you remember how quickly
Ultron went evil oh yeah it was
instantaneous
it's so fast all he does is he connects
to the internet yeah he watches like the
History Channel basically plugs in is
like like corporate Davos multipass like
watching all the atrocities of history
but he just plugs in the internet first
second and he's like no no no humanity
has to go it doesn't he go yeah in that
suite Robert California boys I'm The
Lizard King but what does he know about
humanity that we don't worry psyche no
no no they got to go now
like now otherwise something thinking he
saw us into the future a little bit in
in an algorithmic way to see the new
episode of West world I did okay that
proud but it was pretty good okay that
that big thing they got where it's like
an algorithm and I can see all the
different plans and yes insight yeah
inside Ultron basically probably did
that and he's like oh yeah all signs
point to displaces unless I do this big
thing right he thought he was saving the
day now do you think it was a nuclear
thing cuz that's normally what it is
right the Machine sees a nuclear threats
or or did he see like a disease outbreak
did he see you alright to real did you
see like question Maurice riots mass
shooters those kind of things I mean
that's all everything you've said is in
our past a ecological disaster may be
calm it killed the planet Kyle then he
makes like a little bitch-ass comment
yeah that's a cobia that'd be that'd
probably be the best way to go point is
he knows something we don't about where
we're all headed also a good reason for
him to come back and reveal that to us
so what does ultron know really know and
when did he know it that's a reference
for your parents Oh sometimes I had a
little quick ones that I just woke up in
the middle night and I just wrote down
so fast and I wrote who run Wakanda and
what I met with that was we see a coy
way in endgame as if like she's like the
representative or something but does
that mean that they don't have a new
king post and original snap he's just
been five years and a KO yeas like
blocking off the throne room or
something like why didn't they appoint a
new king I mean it would probably be in
Baku right there when they have an
Wiseman mbaku there
well he's me might not be the oh he
scared of Technology right because it's
beautiful or maybe there's some drama
behind the scenes there like she's a
representative to the Avengers cuz she
was fighting alongside them the longest
okay so my thing is that I think that
there's insane stuff that happened in
Wakanda during those five years and
turmoil and political revolution and a
scramble for the throne and maybe that's
what we seem like Ultron gossip what did
he know yeah but honestly like what
Conda probably went through a really
crazy time there their leader
disappeared and for some reason there
wasn't an obvious replacement just like
yeah but I wrote that one down real fast
it's not that important it's scary um
but and then I also wrote down stones
can bring back vanos which I guess is
just a point it's that whole episode is
just Philip stranger it was that
basically where I realized like well if
they were able to snap bring back
everyone who was dusted they could
somebody could use the stones and bring
back everyone evil that was dusted too
so it was just a note technically Thanos
could come back which actually I kind of
liked but then I started thinking about
Bannos because I couldn't sleep because
I have insomnia for a variety of reasons
now wait what's your judgment you
haven't sought me to you call me in the
middle of the night
That's not me that's my clone and if you
find him you need to tell me where he is
he's way better than anyone I know
that's why he has to go yeah okay so
what I was thinking about daños
is the snap just a simple idea is simple
of what's he want what did what was his
goal joy wipe out half of everything so
to allow corporations to throw a perfect
balance right half the life in the
universe what if that's an odd number
what if there was an odd number of
living things in the universe at the
moment he snapped
round up or round down no he this much
as those who D like I do so you think
there's one poor guy on challah he got
zapped tested exactly but not quite
because I think that guy would still be
alive and he was still like if he got
dusted top half than using that
hilarious Pixar movie if he got dusted
bottom half then he's still gonna eat a
lot or whatever right so that doesn't
count I think he made some dude like
brain dead you just like put him like in
a coma or whatever it needs like this
guy's hassle that's the only way I could
imagine somebody being happy is it like
half of your organs half of your blood
like half your brain no I think he just
had like a donkey kick him in the head
just be like I want and half the life
the universe and then I want Ned Fullmer
subscribe yeah we haven't seen what
happened I bet all four of them survived
they're pretty much there one entity
when he's a big fan but but he made one
guy kind of like not good up here and
that guy was just like half alive I feel
like there's so many more tortuous ways
you can do someone to half a life your
sigh of exasperation that you just had
about my thought made this whole thing
like blow back and forth for a second
what I'm saying is that's a sea
nightmare thinking I'm thinking like in
Chernobyl where you have literally half
that firefighter he has melted down in
that hospital bed I'd rather be a dumb
dumb walking around like Forrest Gump
than living like that guy you should
never enter noble because your baby will
be a mutant mmm it's all my babies
already knew and I live in a school and
I'm going bald and I'm going to be
called scarlet balding Scarlet Witch
glorious okay also thinking about the
Avengers and all the terrible things
that they've brought to this world okay
thinking about if that's really
happening in the world
then the Department of Defense isn't
gonna like lay back and we we already
kind of know that through Ross as their
representative of the government
something they haven't introduced in the
MCU but of course they're working on is
their own altered people like it's been
like like Oh Nazi experiments and Hydra
was creating these mutants to predict of
course the American government is
working on enhanced people and we just
don't know it yet
remember a couple episodes ago we
learned a lot about MKULTRA and how it
goes when the American government of
these experiments on people to try to
turn the Missouri way it's not gonna go
well yeah you think they would just put
Super Soldier Serum and Steve Rogers and
then stop that
after that freakishly successful right
they're gonna be doing everything they
can to try to duplicate but adding some
sort of like mental dampening effect or
something that they can do so they can
fully control that person's I mean don't
that's what extremis was but extremis is
just one bad egg and a batch of eggs of
success stories one of them could be the
Weapon X program I can't find eggs
anywhere hmm I'm I go store to store in
hi hoard eggs because it's all I yeah
only the bad eggs you can leave that
ones yeah they're the saltiest good eggs
turn into chicken if they're good enough
yeah I'm just realizing that of course
there's gonna be a reveal of these
terrible people who are all created by
the government who lead these tragic
lives or maybe they were like soldiers
that came back from war and they get
experimented on and then they get abused
and then maybe they're the thunderbolts
you're trying to get nuke back in this
stuff I love new you love you hate nukes
will you love will Simpson it's will and
one and Frank and the other why did they
change the name who knows he's still
nuke okay and then this one is a real
thought that I'm proud of but I don't
have many of those just thinking about
everything that's happened in the MCU I
was like what would this mean go back to
pre Iron Man one we're essentially
living in our world yes free Iron Man
one
it's a huge deal that Elon Musk
essentially creates you know the
equivalent be Lamas creates iron suit
and you can kind of like fly around a
little bit but people kind of make
things like that and we have a real Elon
Musk and he's a STONER but whatever he
has his own power but it's not that
different from our world cutted like 22
movies later or whatever we have like
gods on the planet
we have Chitauri technology the Infinity
stones of the universe have been brought
mostly to this planet to be dealt with
and then half of all life in the
universe is wiped out who saves them
mostly literal earthling humans
uh-huh so our reputation as earth went
from nothing not a blip on the radar to
probably like the star of the universe
right now I Spit on our partition and
that's why it's there that's why it's
there I and now I'm thinking like earth
is either the equivalent of the guy who
just got to prison and he's like jacked
and I was like week we got a this guy up
in order to show that like that now that
you're playing in the big leagues here
in prison which is what everyone aspires
to that you have to we got to put them
in this place so we're about to get
attacked by everyone or earth now looks
like the wealthy guy that walks down the
street waving around his wallet like an
idiot and it's like we got to go steal
all that Chitauri technology that
Michael Keaton's working on and and
steal they probably have more Infinity
stones I wouldn't even know but like we
just have so much reason now to have
negative attention on us that it's
actually our doom is imminent so you're
saying the Battle of Earth put a target
on a huge target not just a death battle
of Earth everything else that's happened
in all these movies what they're like
man you hear that crazy thing about
danos it's like you know that happened
on earth - right that also happen to
earth everything keeps happening on
earth you know what it is it's like the
story of the Battle of 300 of
Thermopylae and yeah like if everyone
knows that story and how badass those
300 or so are Earthlings they were
earthly and they were also smarter you
were also coincidental off this huge
invasion force and they they stood their
ground and they ended up losing they
lose to the Xerxes hot gunslinger
formless world yes yeah and also but he
loses to a spider and lost so really
everyone loses to someone so I'm just
saying we're all doomed
yeah we really are hey you know one
thing we haven't brought up is that big
tub of goo that covered Missouri and
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 it
xico goo and it's spread out from that
tree and it absorbed of Dairy Queen and
a bunch of cars and not enough people
have talked about that but that would
have been up until that moment be
craziest thing that ever happened in
Missouri unexplained yeah yes second
largest tub of goo if Missouri to ever
explode yeah yeah sharp objects I
remember that and then real quick I just
noted down again
waking up in the middle of the night
having straight thoughts real quick wait
how what do you mean black widow said
she knew Bucky as an adversary or what
what the are we gonna find it out there
were like enemies at one point she knows
him there happen in Budapest what
happened in Budapest I wrote all of that
down exactly and then I wrote where
Gomorrah go and why Gomorrah ha you
leave out a lot of words in your dream
journal well I'm writing with my feet
and so it's all the ice yeah why
sleeping anyway I did cap create a new
timeline that's all messed up question
is the real Mandarin still out there yes
yes okay you know and their Scrolls
still floating around from Captain
Marvel you know what happened to them
there were earthquakes under the sea is
that Namor or is that like global
warming put what's up with that
a little bit of both and then the last
day I wrote you know hydras not gone oh
yeah you can never kill a Hydra it just
grows eight more Idris yeah there's so
many things you know Phillip it's been
terrifying to go down your dream journal
with you but hey when I have nightmares
that keep me up at night I just wake up
from my cot in the blue dungeon and
stand in front of the camera the blue
dungeon and start talking and that's how
you get your videos every day they start
as Eric's nightmares that's beautiful
it's tragic
we don't want people to feel too scared
that is partially why we are drinking
these specific Coors Light they sent
them to us because they're awesome but
they also know that right now we need
some chill yeah we need some show and we
like to chill with Coors Light yes and
my mountain by the way still blue
because they turn blue when they're real
cold yeah when it's chilled to
perfection might still get some streaks
of blue in there it's still pretty
chilly chilly and cold and crispy and a
hundred and five calories which means a
lot
that's why Coors Light is the one we
choose when we need a moment of chill
guys when you want to reset like we all
do right now just reach for the beer
that's actually made to chill hey
celebrate responsibly Cooter's Brewing
Company in Golden Colorado okay on to
some more bite-sized questions Philip
what have you got for me this week
don't just broke quarantine now we wait
not my boat there was a separate I just
hope after that you slowly start to look
like me alright I got bite-sized
questions for you but don't buy it on
because you can put them in your mouth
right now dammit alright so this
question I love I think about this
question all the time I've seen this
question around two so I'm asking you
can Magneto lift Thor's hammer
okay well the Marvel comics have shown
him both lifting at times and not being
able to lift in other times but magneto
is master of all metal but not just the
metal itself it's magnetic field around
the metal so he can manipulate any metal
that's earth based or extraterrestrial
including you
which is what Mjolnir is made out of and
like Shiar technology which is another
alien tech but she was a hottie I had a
thing for her but she had weird arm
things and it made me confused there are
actually three types of magnetism I look
this up there there's Ferro magnetism
that applies to the metallic magnetic
metals iron cobalt and Nicole but
there's also a paramagnetism and
diamagnetism and the other forms of
magnetism apply to all objects just on a
very small level so all things have a
magnetic field around them that most the
times just canceled out by gravity but
magneto has mastery over all forms of
magnetism so theoretically he can
manipulate any object in the comics he's
moved like mountains he's moved trees
just by like manipulating the magnetic
field around them so it's not specific
to metal but just the fact that magneto
can lift Mjolnir using its magnetic
field doesn't mean he is wielding you'll
know but he can like throw it
with he can move it he can deflect it
from attacks on him but he cannot
harness the powers of Thor the way
captain when he lifts him you'll hear
yes but he can pretty much mess with it
yeah I can you know just kind of keep it
right out of his reach oh I'm proud of
us for not making a sexual magnetism
joke or did we okay this next question
comes from Third Ward TX guide on e it's
a very good question about Cyclops is
very effective Ray Bans basically he
wants to know how is it that the Rays
that come from
Cyclops his eyes they can like just they
can level mountains and they can cut
people and have to do all kinds of
things but they don't just like knock
his sunglasses off his face how would
that work
okay so Scott Summers his civilian
sunglasses are made out of the same
material that is optic blast lenses when
he's like it's super hero mode it's made
of this material called Ruby quartz
which in real life is actually very
variable it would fall apart but at the
time in the 60s when Stan Lee was
developing these characters like lasers
were things so he's just kinda like yeah
one will be able to shoot lasers out of
his eyes but people believe that the
Ruby quartz limits the light that comes
into his eyes to just the red part of
the spectrum so Scott Summers when he
walks around he absorbs solar energy
through his body and that's what he
converts into the optic blast but
they're saying that the the reason why
that's just not happening every time you
know he opens his eyes behind every
course is his cones are only being
activated on the red scale from the the
solar light that's coming in however
later canon has further clarified that
Scott's eyes open portals to another
dimension of concussive laser energy
optic energy so every time he opens his
eyes he is opening those gateways those
portals to other dimensions to Ward's
the optic blast yeah but the the
sunglasses and the normal lens that he
has as Cyclops I may have the same
material that prevents that from
happening so it's true what they say the
eyes are a gateway to a laser hell
dimension they do say that this next
question comes up all the time it's from
Scott Greg W he wants to know just
straight up do the Avengers know Coulson
is alive are they still like mourning
him
so this is a fun one that kind of delves
into the matter of Canon in the MCU so
according to Joss Whedon who directed
the pilot of the first agents of shield
episode he's the one who kind of decided
that Agent Coulson was coming back but
he also directed the first two Avengers
movie cleaning age of Ultron
so when age of Ultron was coming out he
clarified that the Avengers do not know
that Coulson is alive Nick Fury knows
Maria hill knows but the rest of the
Avengers are not aware of this in fact
there's an episode of agents of shield
when lady SIF
comes to visit and they have to tell
Lady SIF Don't Tell Thor because
apparently Coulson's death as a martyr
was so important to bind the Avengers
together these dum-dums are gonna be
like wait he's alive then we shouldn't
be Avengers any more right like that's
gonna matter
also Joss Whedon has kind of clarified
that there is a slight difference in
canon between agents of shield and the
rest of the MCU now for all intents and
purposes the agents of shield series is
canon and the MCU there's a ton of
tie-ins their timelines pretty much sync
up until the later seasons but he had
said specifically that the truth of the
TV series is not necessarily the truth
of the cinematic universe and to me the
the biggest defining point is Kevin
Feige really hasn't had a ton of
oversight over agents of shield in the
show so unless it's part of a Kevin
Feige he's master plan for the Cinematic
Universe I don't know if it's
technically canon I mean on agency I
think they eventually got to they have
an alternate timeline yet now - and
Werth is destroyed and stuff so it
definitely is a whole whole thing and
then obviously the Netflix shows also
had their own thing so what happens if
like Agent Coulson is like in a room and
then like Steve Rogers walks in he has
to pretend to be dead yes oh [ __ ] his
pants
like have always been dead yeah he has
to be dead and then someone has to be
like oh we bring his body here again why
did he now shoot his thing we're so
sorry mr. stark oh god that's so bad and
Baronessa drool and like play dead and
we know well you shouldn't draw heat
there he's been dead dead bodies drool
next up it's a big black hood yeah the
dead bodies dreams about me the dream of
a dead person is called heaven oh my god
Erik that's
get that start out of here
okay we have time for one more question
in our mailbag it's in the box go ahead
and get it Eric it's on the other side
of the barrier what are you gonna do
Eric can't I can't do this
Eric go for it we just won't have a
question this week hey this has been fun
I'll get it but hours later have you
ever been bullied by kids when you were
an adult I kind of want a bully Phillip
right now yeah yeah I've been bullied by
my kids when I was an adult I don't know
about you I am so I mentioned the past
episode that skateboarders all know who
I am and they follow me around show me
not about that skateboarders I get it
Tony oh no they hate me and they think
I'm an idiot it's all started when I was
12 years old and I bought vans and I
thought that I would look cool in them
but I don't skateboard so one of my
neighbors who does skateboard he's like
hey cool shoes and Emily thanks and he's
like do you skate and I said no and he
goes poser he screamed it at me and then
I had to walk the wrong the wrong in the
long way around the block so that I
wouldn't past his house but my
girlfriend I went to Venice Beach and
they have a skate park there and that's
one of the cool things to do events
beaches you see like world-class skaters
asking for trouble though with your
reputation well we you go up and you
lean on the rail and you just kind of
like watch them as they do their tricks
and and there was like as we walked up
there was like four kids in a line who
were about to go down the halfpipe thing
and skating there was just like a guy
who seemed to be directing them and my
first Cystic does I just asked my
girlfriend like this is a class and she
goes oh no they're just gating there's
another dude his buddy on the other side
of me who goes what did you ask no it's
not a class they're just skating I was
like okay didn't ask you and then I hear
him tell his buddy
is everybody was like what do you know
he goes this guy thinks it's a class
yeah he's stupid I told him it's not a
class and he's trying to sign up and
they both kind of snicker a little bit
ask either of you if it was a class and
I had you could forgive me for thinking
there would be maybe some kind of free
skate a workshop drop in class but this
these [ __ ] and everytime I see when
it's skateboarders they all give me that
look like this is a guy who thinks it's
a class and his fans what the hell he
doesn't even have a van I'm gonna call
the cops on all of you I'll be stoners
I'm trying to think if I had as you know
I used to tutor kids and for London I
taught SAT classes but those kids like
usually wouldn't make fun of me because
I would I was ruthless I would make fun
of them so much faster and they would
make fun of me the only thing that comes
to mind is actually a little bit of
drama
it's and this I will say the name of the
place it's when I worked at SourceFed
there was a thing there for me where you
and I did improv together for like 10
freaking years and we've known each
other for 38 years at this point we have
an understanding of like comedic rapport
and what we're joking about and what
we're not joking about and off-screen
producer Zack was he did that with us
and like everyone that we normally work
with we we have that shared language
with yeah and then I got to work at
SourceFed where no one and I had that
shared language but also they kind of
came from different places they didn't
kind of come from improv backgrounds out
of them or stand-up comedians or just
just they did YouTube or something so
was a lot of kind of like singular hosts
and then I was very used to our Improv
energy and everybody joking and building
on each other's ideas and so then I
would be in videos and I joke and I
guess the other host movie just didn't
know I was joking or didn't know how to
add to it so I would say something
really weird and then they'd go that's
really weird
and then they would move on and not
acknowledge a and that would be in the
video so one those hosts were so a lot
younger than me so partially that's the
bullying but actually they're very nice
I'm not kind into bullies the actual
bullies were the source of fans not all
of them some of them are so nice and
some of them are ferociously mean and so
I've just started working there and I
started apparently they had like a
subreddit and I start seeing poster like
why is Philip so creepy
and then it's like Philip definitely a
serial killer am i right
and it's like all these things that so
do me yeah and it's like saying that I'm
like I'm insane and I'm creepy and I say
that with these weird disgusting things
it's like well in the in and out of
context fish-out-of-water situation yes
I look like a like loser and weirdo and
killer of some sort of barely but I
would bind those people and don't get
what's coming to them
it's Philip making a joke okay that's
freaking creepy I mean this isn't like
your fault obviously this is there are
different flavors of funny and some
people just think it's people either
funny or they're not but like with you
have something like SourceFed or any
team based Internet yeah like they all
kind of have like their own specific
like shorthand in their language and
sometimes it can be it doesn't always
mix you know oh yeah totally I actually
don't don't blame them it was just like
kind of like a bad mix sort of but I
mean like the jokes we make with like
Tommy or we yeah you just would not fly
well yeah it comes it does come from
just like being on stage with someone
show after show after show after show
and it just kind of like works and you
kind of can instinctively yes and each
other but if you're used to just like
being on you're in your own controlled
little playground where you get to make
like the same kind of like camera jokes
every time and the editors get you and
already loves throw in someone who's
from like a different fish tank into
that fish tank and it's just editors are
gonna be like I don't get it
it's an outsider it's it is a bit like
clicky guys I thanks so much for letting
us hopefully distract you for a little
bit we needed the distraction I know
that I had a nice time just now
hopefully you guys did too and hey you
know what alcohol it's the cause of the
solution to most of life's problems so
feel free to grab a drink with a friend
even if it's be a Skype right now yeah
and reminder that you can dig more deep
into like our backgrounds and our
personal feelings with unfiltered
responses by joining our discord server
the strand it's like really the best way
to get to the heart of either of us and
you can join our discord server by
becoming a patron of new rock stars just
go to patreon.com/scishow for more
details there and also you can get an
audio version of this show by looking
for new rock stars big questions
wherever you get your podcasts and make
sure
send us your big questions for future
episodes by tweeting at new rock stars
with a hashtag big question and hitting
us up in the comments below
we'll work your questions in this show
your question may be the title of the
next episode good job good job
hey I'm Erik Bosse you can find me at
Kiev us anywhere on social media can
follow this guy at Phillip Malina the
same places and follow new rock stars on
socials and hate yeah you know subscribe
to new rock stars here on YouTube share
this show we're making content during
the apocalypse maybe some of your
friends might want to watch it yes see
you next week bye Stacey
[Music]